The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GABRIEL KREIMAN:
What I'd like to do
today is give a very
brief introduction
to neural circuits, why we
study them, how we study them,
and the possibilities
that come out
of understanding
biological codes,
and trying to translate those
ideas into computational codes.
Then I will be a
bit more specific,
and discuss some
initial attempts
at studying the computational
role of feedback signals.
And then I'll switch
gears and talk
for a few minutes about a
couple of things that are not
necessarily related
to things that we've
made any real work on,
but I'm particularly
excited about in the context
of open question challenges,
and opportunities,
and what I think
will happen over the next
several years in the field.
In the hope of
inspiring several of you
to actually solve some of these
open questions in the field.
So one of the reasons why I'm
very excited about studying
biology and studying
brains is that our brains
are the product of millions
of years of evolution.
And through evolution,
we have discovered
how to do things that are
interesting, fast, efficient.
And so if we can understand
the biological cause,
if we can understand
the machinery
by which we do all of
these amazing feats, that
in principle, we
should be able to take
some of these biological
codes, and write
computer code that will
do all of those things
in similar ways.
In similar ways that we can
write algorithms to compute
the square root
of 2, there could
be algorithms that
dictate how we
see, how we can
recognize objects,
how we can recognize
auditory events.
In short, the answer to all
of these Turing questions,
in some sense, is
hidden somewhere here
inside our brain.
So the question is, how can we
listen to neurons and circuits,
decode their activity,
and maybe even write
in information in
the brain, and then
trying to translate all of these
ideas into computational codes.
So there's a lot of
fascinating properties
that biological codes cover.
Needless to say,
we're not quite there
yet in terms of
computers and robots.
So our hardware and software
worked for many decades.
I think it's very unlikely
that your amazing iPhone 6 or 5
or 7 whatever it is, will last
four, five, six, seven, eight,
nine decades.
None of our computers
will last that long.
Our hardware does.
There's amazing
parallel computation
going on in our brains.
This is quite
distinct from the way
we think about algorithms and
computation in other domains
now.
Our brains have a
reprogrammable architecture.
The same chunk of
tissue can be used
for several different purposes.
Through learning and
through our experiences,
we can modify those
architectures.
A thing that has been
quite interesting,
and that maybe
we'll come back to,
is the notion of being able
to do single shot learning, as
opposed to some machine
learning algorithms that require
lots and lots of data to train.
We can easily discover
a structure in data.
The notion of fault
tolerance and robustness
to transformations
is an essential one.
Robustness is arguably
a fundamental property
of biology and one that has been
very, very hard to implement
in computational circuitry.
And for engineers,
the whole issue
about how to have different
systems integrate information,
and interact with each
other, has been and continues
to be a fundamental challenge.
And our brains do
that all the time.
We're walking down
the street, we
can integrate
visual information,
with auditory information with
our targets, our plans, what
we're interested in doing, on
social interactions, and so on.
So why do we want to
study neural circuits.
So I think we are
in the golden era
right now, because we can begin
to explore the answers to some
of these Turing questions in
brains at the biological level.
So we can study high
level cognitive phenomena
at the level of neurons,
and circuits of neurons.
And I'll give you a few
examples of that later on.
More recently, and I'll come
back to this towards the end,
we've had the
opportunity to begin
to manipulate, and disrupt, and
interact with neural circuits
at unprecedented resolution.
So we can begin
to turn on and off
specific subsets of neurons.
And that has tremendously
accelerated our possibility
to test theories at
the neural level.
And then again, the notion being
that empirical findings can
be translated into
computational algorithms-- that
is, if we really understand
how biology solves the problem,
in principle, we
should be able to write
mathematical equations, and
then write code that mimics
some of those computations.
And some of the
examples of that, we
talk about in the visual
system in my presentation,
but also in Jim
DiCarlo's presentation.
These are just advertising
for a couple of books
that I find interesting
and relevant
in computational neuroscience.
I'm not going to have
time to do any justice
to the entire field of
computation neuroscience
at all.
So all these slides
will be in Dropbox,
so if anyone wants
to learn more about
computational neuroscience.
These are lot of
tremendous books.
Larry Abbott is the
author of this one,
and he'll be talking tonight.
So how do we study
biological circuitry.
And I realize that this is
deja vu and very well known
for many of you.
But in general,
we have a variety
of techniques to probe the
function of brain circuits.
And this is showing
the temporal resolution
of different techniques,
and the spatial resolution
of different techniques used
to study neural circuits.
All the way from
techniques that have
limited spatial and
temporal resolution,
such as PET and fMRI--
techniques that have very
high temporal resolution,
but relatively poor
spatial resolution--
all the way to
techniques that allow
us to interrogate the function
of individual channels
with neurons.
So most of what I'm
going to talk about today
is what we refer to as the
neural circuit level, somewhere
in between single neurons
and then ensembles of neurons
recording the local
field potential,
which give us the resolution
of milliseconds, where we think
a lot of the computations
in the cortex are happening,
and where we think we can
begin to elucidate how neurons
interact with each other.
So to start from
the very beginning,
we need to understand
what a neuron does.
And again, many of you are
quite familiar with this.
But the basic
fundamental understanding
of what a neuron does is to
integrate information-- receive
information through
its dendrites,
integrates that
information, and decides
whether to fire a spike or not.
Interestingly, some of the
basic intuitions of our neuron
function were essentially
conceived by a Spaniard,
Ramón y Cajal.
He wanted to be an artist.
His parents told him that he
could not become an artist,
he had to become a
clinician, a medical doctor.
So he followed the tradition.
He became a medical doctor.
But then he said, well, what I
really like doing is drawing.
And so he bought a microscope,
he put it in his kitchen,
and he spent a good chunk of
his life drawing, essentially.
So he would look at neurons,
and he would draw their shapes.
And that's essentially
how neuroscience started.
Just from these beautiful
and amazing array
of drawings of neurons, he
conjectured the basic flow
of information.
This notion that this
integration of information
through dendrites, all
of this integration
happens in the soma.
And from there, neurons decide
whether to fire a spike or not.
Nothing more, nothing less.
That's essentially
the fundamental unit
of computation in our brains.
How do we think about and
model those processes?
There's a family of
different types of models
that people have used to
describe what a neuron does.
These models differ in terms
of their biological accuracy,
and their computational
complexity.
One of the most used ones is
perhaps an integrate and fire
neuron.
This is a very
simple RC circuit.
It basically integrates current,
and then through a threshold,
the neuron decides when to
fire or not to fire a spike.
This is essentially treating
neurons as point masses.
There are people out there
who have argued that you
need more and more detail.
You need to know exactly
how many dendrites you have,
and the position
of each dendrite,
and on and on and on and on.
What's the exact
resolution at which we
should study neuron systems is
a fundamental open question.
We don't know what's the
right level of abstraction.
There are people who think about
brains in the context of blood
flow, and millions and millions
of neurons averaged together.
There are people who
think that we actually
need to pay attention to
the exact details of how
every single dendrite integrates
information, and so on.
For many of us, this
is a sufficient level
of abstraction.
The notion that there's a neuron
that can integrate information.
So we would like
to push this notion
that we can think about
models with single neurons,
and see how far we can go,
understanding that we are
ignoring a lot of the inner
complexity of what's happening
inside a neuron itself.
So very, very
briefly just to push
the notion that this
is not rocket science.
It's very, very easy to build
these integrate-and-fire model
simulations.
I know many of you do
this on a daily basis.
This is the equation
of the RC circuit.
There's current that flows
through a capacitance.
through the resistance, which,
this RC circuit, we think of
as composed of the ion channels
in the membranes of the neurons.
And this is all there
is to it in terms
of a lot of the simulation
that we use to understand
the function of neurons.
And again, just to
tell you that there's
nothing scary or fundamentally
difficult about this,
here's just a couple
of lines in MATLAB
that you can take a
look at if you've never
done these kind of simulations.
This is a very simple and
perhaps even somewhat wrong
simulation of an
integrate-and-fire neuron.
But just to tell you that it's
relatively simple to build
models of individual
neurons that
have these
fundamental properties
of being able to integrate
information, and decide
when to fire a spike.
The fundamental
questions that we really
want to tackle in
CBMM have to do
with putting together
lots of neurons,
and understanding the
function of circuits.
It's not enough to understand
individual neurons.
We need to understand how
they interact together.
We want to understand
what is there,
who's there, what are they doing
to whom, and when, and why.
We really need to understand
the activity of multiple neurons
together in the
form of circuitry.
So just a handful of
basic definitions.
If we have a
circuitry like this,
where we start connecting
multiple neurons together,
information flows here in this
circuitry in this direction.
We refer to the
connections between neurons
that go in this direction
as feed forward.
We refer to the connections that
flow in the opposite direction
as feedback and I use the
word recurrent connections
for the horizontal connections
within a particular layer.
So this is just to
fix the nomenclature
for the discussion that
will come next, and also
today in the afternoon with
Jim DiCarlo's presentation.
Throughout a lot
of anatomical work,
we have begun to elucidate
some of the basic connectivity
between neurons in the cortex.
And this is the
primary example that
has been cited extremely
often of what we understand
about the connectivity
between different areas
in the macaque monkey.
We don't have a diagram like
this for the human brain.
Most of the detailed
anatomical work
has been done in
macaque monkeys.
So each of these boxes here
represents a brain area,
and this encapsulates
our understanding
of who talks to
whom, or which area
talks to which other area
in terms of visual cortex.
There's a lot of
different parts of cortex
that represent
visual information.
Here at the bottom,
we have the retina.
Information from the retina
flows through to the LGN.
From the LGN, information
goes to primary visual cortex,
sitting right here.
And from there,
there's a cascade
that is largely parallel, and
at the same time, hierarchical,
of a conglomerate
of multiple areas
that are fundamental in
processing visual information.
We'll talk about some
of these areas next.
And we'll also talk
about some of these areas
today in the afternoon
when Jim discusses
what are the fundamental
computations involved
in visual object recognition.
One of the fundamental
clues as to how
do we understand, how
do we know that this
is a particular
visual area, how do
we know that this is
important for our vision,
has come from
anatomical lesions.
Mostly in monkeys, but in
some cases, in humans as well.
So if you make lesions
in some of these areas,
depending on exactly where
you make that lesion,
people either become
completely blind,
or they have a
particular scotoma,
a particular chunk of the visual
field where they cannot see.
Or they have more
high order types
of deficits in terms
of visual recognition.
As an example, the
primary visual cortex
was discovered by people who
were of the [INAUDIBLE] they
were studying, the trajectory
of bullets in soldiers
during World War I.
And by discovering
that some of those
peoples had a blind part
to their visual field, and that
was a topographically organized
depending on the particular
trajectory of the bullet
through their occipital cortex.
And that's how we became to
think about V1 as fundamental
in visual processing.
It is not a perfect hierarchy.
It's not there is
A, B, C, D. Right?
For a number of reasons.
One is that there are lots
of parallel connections.
There are lots of
different stages
that are connected
to each other.
And one of the ways
to define a hierarchy
is by looking at the
timing of the responses
in different areas.
So if you look at the average
latency of the response in each
of these areas, you'll
find that there's
an approximate hierarchy.
Information gets out of the
retina approximately at 50
milliseconds.
About 60 or so milliseconds
in LGN, and so on.
So it's approximately
a 10 millisecond cost
per step in terms of
the average latency.
However, if you start
looking at the distribution,
you'll see that it's
not a strict hierarchy.
For example, there are
neurons in area V4 that
are the early neurons
in V4 may fire
before the late neurons in V1.
And that shows you that the
circuitry is far more complex
than just a simple hierarchy.
One way to put some
order into this seemingly
complex and chaotic
circuitry, one simplification
is that there are
two main pathways.
One is the so-called
what pathway.
The other one is the
so-called where pathway.
The what pathway essentially
is the ventral pathway.
It's mostly involved
in object recognition,
trying to understand
what is there.
The dorsal pathway,
the where pathway,
is most involved in
motion, and being
able to detect where objects
are, stereo, and so on.
Again, this is not
a strict division,
but it's a pretty good
approximation that many of us
have used in terms of
thinking about the fundamental
computations in these areas.
Now we often think
about these boxes,
but of course, there's a
huge amount of complexity
within each of these boxes.
So if we zoom in
one of these areas,
we discover that there's
a complex hierarchy
of computations.
There are multiple
different layers.
The cortex is essentially
a six layer structure.
And there are specific rules.
People have referred to this
as a canonical micro circuitry.
There's a specific set of rules
in terms of how information
flows from one layer to
another in terms of each
of these cortical structures.
To a first approximation,
this canonical circuitry
is common to most
of these areas.
There are these
rules about which
layer receives information
first, and sends
information to areas
are more or less
constant throughout
the cortical circuitry.
This doesn't mean that we
understand this circuitry well,
or what each of these
connections is doing.
We certainly don't.
But these are initial steps
to sort of decipher some
of these basic biological
connectivity that
has fundamental computational
properties for vision
processing.
So our lab has been
very interested in what
we call the first
order approximation
or immediate approximation
to visual object recognition.
The notion that we can
recognize objects very fast,
and that this can be
explained, essentially,
as the bottom-up
hierarchical process.
Jim DiCarlo is going to
talk about this extensively
this afternoon, so I'm going to
essentially skip that, and jump
into more recent work that
we've done trying to think
about top-down connections.
But just let me
briefly say why we
think that the first pass
of visual information
can be semi-seriously
approximated by these purely
bottom-up processing.
One is that at the
behavioral level,
we can recognize
objects very, very fast.
There's a series of
psychophysical experiments
that demonstrate that
if I show you an object,
recognition can happen within
about 150 milliseconds or so.
We know that the
physiological signals
underlying visual
object recognition also
happen very fast.
Within about 100 to
150 milliseconds,
we can find neurons that
show very selective responses
to complex objects, and again,
you'll see examples of that
this afternoon.
The behavior and the physiology
have inspired generations
of computational models that are
purely bottom-up, where there
is no recurrency, and that can
be quite successful in terms
of visual recognition.
To our first approximation,
the recent excitement
with deep convolutional
networks can be traced back
to some of these ideas, and
some of these basic biologically
inspired computations
that are purely bottom-up.
So to summarize--
and I'm not going
to give any more details--
we think that the first 100
milliseconds or so
of visual processing
can be approximated by
these purely bottom-up,
semi hierarchical
sequence of computations.
And this leaves open a
fundamental question,
which is, why we have all these
massive feedback connections?
We know that in cortex,
there are actually
more recurrent and
feedback connections
than feed-forward ones.
And what I'd like
to talk about today
is a couple of ideas of what all
of those feedback connections
may be doing.
So this is an anatomical study
looking at a lot of the boxes
that I showed you
before, and showing
how many of the connections
to any given area
come from one of
these other variants.
For example, if we take
just primary visual cortex,
this is saying that
a good fraction
of the connections to
primary visual cortex
actually come from V2.
That's from the next
stage of processing,
rather than from V1 itself.
All in all, if you quantify
for a given neuron in V1,
how many signals are coming
from a bottom-up source that
is for LGN versus how
many signals are coming
from other V1 neurons or
from higher visual areas,
it turns out that there are
more horizontal and top-down
projections than bottom-up ones.
So what are they doing?
If we can approximate the
first 100 milliseconds or so
of vision so well with
bottom-up hierarchies,
what are all these
feedback signals doing?
So this brings me
to three examples
that I'd like to discuss
today of recent work
that we've done to take some
initial principles in thinking
about what this feedback
connections could be doing
in terms of visual recognition.
So I'll start by
giving you an example
of trying to understand
the basic fundamental unit
of feedback.
That is these
canonical computations,
and by looking at the feedback
that happens from V2 to V1
in the visual system.
Next, I'm going to give
you an example of what
happens during a visual
search, where we also
think that feedback signals may
be playing a fundamental role,
if you have to do or Where's
Waldo kind of task, where
you have to search for objects
and in the environment.
And finally, I will talk
about pattern completion, how
you can recognize objects that
are heavily occluded, where
we also think that
feedback signals may
be playing an important role.
So before I go on
to describe what
we're seeing the feedback
from V2 to V1 maybe doing,
let me describe very
quickly classical work
that Hubel and Wiesel did
that got them the Nobel Prize
by recording the
activity of neurons
in primary visual cortex.
They started working
in kittens, and then
subsequently in
monkeys, and discovered
that there are neurons that
show orientation tuning, meaning
that they respond
very vigorously.
These are spikes,
each of these marks
corresponds to an
action potential,
the fundamental language
of computation in cortex.
And this neuron responds
quite vigorously
when the cat was seeing a
bar of this orientation.
And essentially,
there's no firing
at all with this
type of stumulus
in the receptive field.
This was fundamental because it
transformed our understanding
of the essential computations
in primary visual cortex
in terms of filtering
the initial stimulus.
This is what we now
describe by Gabor functions.
And if you look at deep
convolutional networks,
many of them, if not
perhaps all of them,
start with some sort
of filtering operation
that is either Gabor filters
or resembles this type
of orientation that we think
is a fundamental aspect of how
we start to process information
in the visual field.
One of the beautiful things
that Hubel and Wiesel did
is not only to make
these discoveries,
but also to come up with very
simple graphical models of how
they thought this
could come about.
And this remains today one
of the fundamental ways
in which we think about how
our orientation tuning may
come about.
If you recall the activity
of neurons in the retina
or in the LGN,
you'll find what's
called center surround
receptive fields.
These are circularly
symmetric receptive fields,
with an area in the center
that excites the neuron,
and an area in the surround
that inhibits the neuron.
What they conjecture is that if
you put together multiple LGN
cells, whose receptive
fields are aligned
along a certain orientation, and
you simply combine all of them,
you simply add the responses
of all of those neurons,
you can get a neuron in
the primary visual cortex
that has orientation tuning.
This
is a problem that's far from
solved, despite the fact
that we have four
or five decades.
There are many,
many models of how
orientation tuning comes about.
But this remains one of the
basic bottom-up feed-forward
ideas of how you
can actually build
orientation tuning from very
simple receptive fields.
This has informed a
lot of our thinking
about how basic
computations can give rise
to orientation tuning in a
purely bottom-up fashion.
In primary visual
cortex, in addition
to the so-called simple
cells, are complex cells
that show invariance
to the exact position
or the exact phase
of the oriented bar
within the receptive field.
And that's illustrated here.
So this is a simple cell.
So this simple cell
has orientation tuning,
meaning that it responds more
vigorously to this orientation
than to this orientation.
However, if you change the phase
or the position of the oriented
bar within the receptive
field, the response
decreases significantly.
In contrast to this
complex cell that not only
has orientation
tuning, meaning that it
fires more vigorously to this
orientation than to this one,
but also has phase invariance,
meaning that the response is
more or less the same way,
regardless of the exact phase
or the exact position
of the stimulus
within the receptive field.
And again, the notion
that they postulated
is that we can build
these complex cells
by a summation of activity
or multiple simple cells.
So again, if you
imagine now that you
have multiple simple cells
with different receptive fields
that are centered at
these different positions,
you can add them up, and
create complex cells.
These fundamental operations
of simple and complex cells
and primary visual cortex
can be somehow traced
to the root of a lot of the
bottom-up hierarchical models.
A lot of the deep
convolutional networks today
essentially have variations
on these kind of themes,
of filtering steps,
nonlinear computations
that give you invariance,
and a concatenation
of these filtering
and invariance steps
along the visual hierarchy.
So in following
up with this idea,
I would like to understand
the basics of what's
the kind of information that's
provided when you have signals
from V2 to V1.
To do that, we have
been collaborating
with Richard Born at Harvard
Medical School, who has
a way of implanting cryo loops.
This is a device that can be
implanted in monkeys in areas
V2, and V3, lower
the temperature,
and thus reduce or
essentially eliminate activity
from areas V2 and V3.
So that means that we can
study V1 without activity
in area V2 and V3.
We can study V1 sans feedback.
So this is an
example of recordings
of a neuron in this area.
This is the normal activity
that you get from the neuron.
Here is when they present
a visual stimulus.
This is a spontaneous activity.
Each of these dots
corresponds to a spike.
Each of these lines
correspond to a repetition
of the stimulus.
This is a traditional way
of showing raster plots
for neuron responses.
So you see that this is
a spontaneous activity.
You present the stimulus.
There's an increase in the
response of this neuron,
as you might expect.
Actually, I'm sorry.
This actually starts here.
So this is the spontaneous
activity, this is the response.
Now here, they
turn on their pump.
They start lowering
the temperature.
And you see within
a couple of minutes,
they essentially significantly
reduce the responses.
The largely silence--
not completely--
but largely silence
activity in areas V2 and V3.
And these are reversible, so
when they turn the pumps off,
activity comes back in.
So the question is, what
happens in primary visual cortex
when you don't have
feedback from V2 and V3.
So the first thing
they have characterized
is that some of the basic
properties of V1 do not change.
It's consistent with
the simple models
that I just told you, where
the orientation tuning
in the primary visual
cortex is largely
dictated by the
bottom-up inputs,
by the signals from the LGN.
The conjecture
from that would be
that if you silence
V2 and V3, nothing
would happen with
orientation tuning
in primary visual cortex.
And that's essentially
what they're showing here.
These are example neurons.
This is showing
orientation selectivity.
direction selectivity,
what happens when
you move an oriented
bar within the receptive field.
So this is showing
the direction.
This is showing the
mean normalized response
of a neuron.
This is the preferred direction,
and direction orientation
that gives a maximum response.
The blue curve corresponds
to when you don't
have activity in V2 and V3.
Red corresponds to
their control data.
And essentially, the tuning
of the neuron was not altered.
The orientation preferred by
this neuron was not altered.
The same thing goes for
direction selectivity.
So the basic problems
of orientation tuning
and direction selectivity
did not change.
Let me say a few words about
the dynamics of the responses.
So here, what I'm showing you
is the mean normalized responses
as a function of time.
Time 0 is when the
stimulus is turned on.
As I told you already, by
about 50 milliseconds or so,
you get a vigorous response
in primary visual cortex.
And if we compare the
orange and the blue curves,
we see that this initial
response is largely identical.
So the initial response
of these V1 neurons
is not affected by the
absence of feedback from V2.
We start to see
effects, we start
to see a change in
the firing rate here.
Largely at about 60 milliseconds
or so after presentation.
So in a highly
oversimplified cartoon,
I think of this as a bottom-up
Hubel and Wiesel like response,
driven by LGN.
And signals from V2
to V1 coming back
about 10 milliseconds later.
And that's when we started
seeing some of these feedback
related effects.
I told you that some of the
basic properties do not change.
We interpret this as
being dictated largely
by bottom-up signals.
The dynamics do change.
The initial response
is unaffected.
The later part of the
response is affected.
I want to say one
thing that does change.
And for that, I need to
explain what an area summation
curve is.
So if you present the
stimulus within the receptive
field of a neuron of this size,
you get a certain response.
As you start increasing
the size of this stimulus,
you get a more
vigorous response.
Size matters.
The larger, the better--
to a point.
There comes a point
where it turns out
that the response of the
neurons starts decreasing again.
So larger is not always better.
A little bit larger is better.
This size has an
inhibitory effect
overall on the
response of the neuron.
This is called
surround suppression.
And these curves have been
characterized in areas
like primary visual cortex.
Also in earlier areas
for a very long time.
It turns out that when you
do these type of experiments
in the absence of feedback, the
effect of surround suppression
does not disappear.
That is, you still have a peak
in the response as a function
of a stimulus size.
But there is a reduced amount
of surround suppression.
That is, when you
don't have feedback,
there's less suppression.
You have a larger response
for bigger stimulus.
So we think that one of the
fundamental computations
that feedback is
providing here is
this integration from
multiple neurons in V1
that happens in V2.
And then inhibition to
activity of neurons in area V1
to provide some of
the suppression.
This is partly the reason
why our neurons are not
very excited about a uniform
stimulus, like a blank wall.
Our neurons are interested
in changes, and part of that,
we think, is dictated by
this feedback from V2 to V1.
We can model these center
surround interactions
as a ratio of two Gaussian
curves, two forces.
One is the one that
increases the response.
The other one is a
normalization term
that suppresses the response
when the stimulus is too large.
There's a number
of parameters here.
Essentially, you
can think of this
as a ratio of Gaussians, ROGs.
There's a ratio of
two Gaussian curves.
One dictating the
center that responds.
The other one, the
surround response.
And to make a long
story short, we
can feed the data
from the monkey
with this extremely simple
ratio of Gaussian's model.
And we can show that
the main parameter
that feedback seems to be
acting upon is what we call Wn--
that is this
normalization factor here.
So that the tuning
factor that dictates
the strength of the surrounding
division from V2 to V1--
we think that's one of the
fundamental things that's
being affected by feedback.
So we would think
of this as the gain.
We think of this as
the spatial extent
over which the V2
can exert its action
on primary visual cortex.
We think that's the main
thing that's affected here.
This type of spatial
effect may be
important in other role that
has been ascribed to feedback,
which is the ability
to direct attention
to specific locations
in the environment.
I want to come back
to this question
here, and ask, under
what conditions,
and how can a feedback also
provide important features
specific signals from
one area to another.
And for that, I'm
going to switch
to another task, another
completely different prep,
which is the
Where's Waldo task--
the task of visual search.
How do we search for particular
objects in the environment.
And here, it's not sufficient
to focus on a specific location,
but we need to be able to
search for specific features.
We need to be able to
bias our visual responses
for specific features
of the stimulus
that we're searching for.
So this is a famous sort
of Where's Waldo task.
You need to be able to
search for specific features.
It's not enough to be able to
send feedback from V2 to V1,
and direct attention, or change
the sizes of the receptive
fields, or the direct attention
to a specific location.
Another version
that I'm not going
to talk about of visual that
has a related theme that relates
to visual search is
feature based attention,
when you're actually paying
attention to a particular face,
to a particular color, to a
particular feature that is not
necessarily located, and to
space, as our friend here has
studied quite significantly.
People always like to know
the answer of where he is at.
OK.
So let me tell you about
a computational model
and some behavioral data
that we have collected
to try to get at this question
of how feedback signals can
be relevant for visual search.
This initial part of
this computational model
is essentially the HMAX
type of architecture
that has been pioneered by
Tommy Poggio and several people
in his lab, most notably,
people like Max Riesenhuber
and Thomas Serre.
I was thinking
that by this time,
people would have described
this in more detail.
I'm going to go through
these very quickly.
Again, today in the
afternoon, we'll
have more discussion about
this family of models.
So these family of
models essentially
goes through a series of linear
and non-linear computations
in a hierarchical way, inspired
by the basic definition
of simple and
complex cells that I
described in the work
of Hubel and Wiesel.
So basically, what these models
do is they take an image.
These are pixels.
There's a filtering step.
This filtering step involves
Gabor filtering of the image.
In this particular
case, there are
four different orientations.
And what do you
get here is a map
of the visual input after
this linear filtering process.
The next step in this model
is a local max operation.
This is pooling neurons that
have similar identical feature
preferences, but
slightly different scale
in the receptive fields.
Or slightly different positions
in their receptive fields.
And this max operation,
this non-linear operation
is giving you invariance
to the specific feature.
So now you can get a response to
the same feature, irrespective
of the exact scale
or the exact position
within the receptive field.
These were labeled
S1 and C1, initially
in models by Fukushima.
And this type of nomenclature
was carried on later
by Tommy and many others.
And this is directly inspired
by the simple and complex cells
that I very briefly
showed you previously
in the recordings
of Hubel and Wiesel.
These filtering
and max operations
are repeated throughout the
hierarchy again and again.
So here's another layer
that has a filtering
step and a nonlinear max step.
In this case, this filtering
here is not a Gabor filter.
We don't really understand very
well what neurons in V2 and V4
are doing.
One of the types of
filters that have been used
and that we are using here
is a radial basis function,
where the properties of
a neuron in this case
are dictated by patches taking
randomly from natural images.
All of this is
purely feed-forward.
All of this is essentially
the basic ingredient
of the type of
convolutional networks
that had been used for
object recognition.
You can have more layers.
You can have different
types of computations.
The basic properties
are essentially
the ones that are
described briefly here.
What I really want to talk
about is not the former part,
but this part of the model.
Now I ask you, where's Waldo,
you need to do something,
you need be able to somehow
look at this information,
and be able to
bias your responses
or bias the model towards
regions of the visual space
that have features that resemble
what you're looking for.
Your car, your keys, Waldo.
So the way we do that
is first, in this case,
I'm going to show you
what happens if you're
looking for the top hat here.
So first, we have
a representation
in the model of the top hat.
This is the hat here.
And we have a representation
in our vocabulary
of how units in the highest
echelons of this model
represent this hat.
So we have a representation
of the features
that compose this object at
a high level in this model.
We use that representation
to modulate,
in a multiplicative
fashion, the entire image.
Essentially, we
bias the responses
in the entire image based
on the particular features
that we are searching for.
This is inspired by many
physiological experiments that
have shown that to a
good approximation,
this type of
modulation in feature
based attention has been
observed across different parts
of the visual field.
That is, if you're
searching for red objects,
neurons that like red will
enhance their response
throughout the
entire visual field.
So have the entire
visual field modulated
by the pattern of features that
we're searching for in here.
After that, we have
a normalization step.
This normalization
step is critical
in order to discount
purely bottom-up effects.
We don't want the competition
between different objects
to be purely dictated by
which object is brighter,
for example.
So we normalize that
after modulating that
with the features
that we are searching.
That gives us a map of the
image, where each area has been
essentially compared
to this feature set
that we're looking for.
And then we have a winner
take all mechanism that
dictates where the model
will pay attention to,
or where the model
will fixate on first.
Where the model thinks that a
particular object is located.
OK so what happens when we
have this feedback that's
feature specific, and that
modulates the responses based
on the targets object
that we're searching for.
In these two images,
either in objects
arrays or when objects are
embedded in complex scenes,
we're searching for
this top object.
And the largest
response in the model
is indeed in the location
of where the object is.
In these other two
images, the model
is searching for
this accordion here.
And again, the model
was able to find that
by this comparison of the
features with the stimulus.
More generally, these
are object array images.
This is the number
of fixations required
to find the object in
this object array images.
So one would correspond
to the first fixation.
If the model does not find the
object in the first location,
there's what's called
inhibition of return.
So we make sure the
model does not come back
to the same location,
and the model will
look at the second best
possible location in the image.
And it will keep on searching
until it finds the object.
So the model performs in the
first fixation at 60% correct.
And eventually,
after five fixations,
it can find the object
almost always right in here.
This is what you would
expect by random search.
If you were to randomly
fixate on different objects,
so the model is doing
much better than that.
And then for the
aficionados, there's
a whole plethora of purely
bottom-up models that
don't have feedback whatsoever.
This is a family
of models that was
pioneered by people like
Laurent Itti and Christof Koch.
These are saliency based models.
Although you cannot see, there
are a couple of other points
in here.
All of those models cannot
find the object either.
It's not that these objects
that we're searching for
are more salient,
and therefore, that's
why the model is finding them.
We really need
something more than just
bottom-up pure saliency.
We did a psychophysical
experiment.
We asked, well, this is how
the model searches for Waldo.
How will humans
search for objects
under the same conditions.
So we had multiple objects.
Subjects have to make a
saccade to a target object.
To make a long story short, this
is the cumulative performance
of the model and the
number of fixations
under these conditions,
and the model
that's reasonable in terms
of how well humans do.
This is data from every single
individual subject in the task.
I'm going to skip
some of the details.
You can compare the errors
that the model is making.
How consistent people are
with themselves with respect
to other subjects.
How good it is with
respect to humans.
The long story is the
model is far from perfect.
We don't think that
we have captured
everything we need to
understand about visual search.
Some people alluded to before,
for example, the notion
that the model doesn't
have these major changes
with eccentricity, and
the fovea, and so on.
A long way to go, but
we think that we've
captured some of the
essential initial ingredients
of visual search.
And that this is one example of
how visual feedback signals can
influence this bottom-up
hierarchy for recognition.
I want to very quickly
move on to a third example
that I wanted to give you
of how feedback can help
in terms of visual recognition.
What are other functions that
feedback could be playing.
And for that, I'd like to
discuss the work that Hanlin
did here, and also,
Bill Lotter in the lab,
in terms of how we
can recognize objects
that are partially occluded.
This happens all the time.
So you walk around and
see objects in the world.
You can also encounter
objects where you can only
find partial
information, and you have
to make pattern completion.
Pattern completion is
a fundamental aspect
of intelligence.
We do that in all
sorts of scenarios.
It's not just
restricted to vision.
All of you can probably
complete all of these patterns.
We use pattern completion
in social scenarios
as well, right?
You make inferences
from partial knowledge
about their intentions,
and what they're doing,
and what they're
trying to do, OK?
So we want to study this problem
of how you complete pattern,
how you extrapolate from
partial limited information
in the context of
visual recognition.
There are a lot
of different ways
in which one can present
partially occluded objects.
Here are just a few of them.
What Hanlin did was
use a paradigm called
bubbles that's shown here.
Essentially, it's like looking
at the world like these.
You only have small
windows through which
you can see the object.
Performance can be titrated to
make the task harder or easier.
So if you have a
lot of bubbles, it's
relatively easy to recognize
that this is a toy school bus.
If you have only
four bubbles, it's
actually pretty challenging.
So we can titrate performance
on the difficulty of this task.
Very quickly, let me start
by showing you psychophysics
performance here.
This is how subjects
perform as a function
of the amount of occlusion in
the image as a function of how
many pixels you're
showing for these images.
And what you see here is
that with 60% occlusion,
performance is extremely high.
Performance essentially
drops to chance level
when the object is
more and more occluded.
There is a significant
amount of robustness
in human performance.
For example, you have
a little bit more
than 10% of the
pixels in the object,
and people can still recognize
them reasonably well.
So this is all behavioral data.
Let me show you very quickly
what Hanlin discovered
by doing invasive
recordings in human patients
while the subjects
were performing
this recognition of objects
that are partially occluded.
It's illegal to put
electrodes in the human brain
in normal people, so
we work with subjects
that have pharmacological
intractable epilepsy.
So inside of subjects
that have seizures,
the neurosurgeons need to
implant electrodes in order
to localize the seizures.
And B, in order to ensure
that when they do a resection,
and they take out the
part of the brain that's
responsible for seizures,
that they're not
going to interfere with other
functions, such as language.
These patients stay in the
hospital for about one week.
And during this one week,
we have a unique opportunity
to go inside a human brain,
and record physiological data.
Depending on the
type of patient,
we've used the different
types of electrodes.
This is what some people
refer to as ECoG electrodes.
Electrocorticographic signals.
These are field
potential signals,
very different from the
ones that I was showing you
in the little spikes before.
These are aggregate measures,
probably of tens of thousands,
if not millions of neurons,
where we have very, very
high temporal resolution at
the millisecond level, but very
poor spatial resolution, only
being able to localize things
at the millimeter level or so.
With these, we can
pinpoint specific locations
within about approximately
one millimeter,
but have very high signal to
noise ratio signals that are
dictated by the visual input.
An example of those
signals is shown here.
These are intracranial
field potentials
as a function of time.
This is the onset
of the stimulus.
And these 39
different repetitions,
when Hanlin is showing
this unoccluded face,
we see a very vigorous
change, quite systematic
from one trial to another.
All of those gray traces
are single trials,
similar to the raster plot
that I was showing you before.
So now I'm going to show you
a couple of single trials.
We're showing
individual images where
objects are partially occluded.
In this case, there's
only about 15%
of the pixels of the face
that are being shown.
And we see that despite
the fact that we're
covering 85%, more or
less, of that image,
we still see a pretty
consistent physiological signal.
The signals are
clearly not identical.
For example, this one
looks somewhat different.
There's a lot of our
ability from one to another.
But again, these are just single
trials showing that there still
is selectivity for these
shape, despite the fact
that we are only showing a
small fraction of this thing.
These are all the trials
in which these five
different faces were presented.
Each line corresponds to trial.
These are raster plots.
As you can see, the data
are extremely clear.
There's no processing here.
This is raw data single trials.
These are single trials
with the partial images.
You again can see there's
a vigorous response here.
The responses are not
as nicely and neatly
aligned here, in part
because all of these images
are different.
All of the locations on
the models are different.
As I just showed you, there's
a lot of variability here.
If you actually fix the
bubble locations-- that
is, you repeatedly present the
same image multiple times still
in pseudorandom order,
but the same image,
you see that the signals
are more consistent.
Not as consistent as this one,
but certainly more consistent.
Again, very clear
selective response
tolerant to a tremendous amount
of occlusion in the image.
Interestingly, the
latency of the response
is significantly later
compared to the whole images.
So if you look at, for
example, 200 milliseconds,
you see that the responses
started significantly
before 200 milliseconds
for the whole images.
All of the responses here
start after 200 milliseconds.
We spent a significant
amount of time
trying to characterize
this and showing
that pattern
completion, the ability
to recognize objects
that are occluded,
involves a significant delay
at the physiological level.
If you use the purely bottom-up
architecture and tried to do
this in silico--
this bottom-up model does
not perform very well.
The performance
deteriorates quite rapidly
when you start having
significant occlusion.
I'm going to skip this and just
very quickly argue about some
of the initial steps
that Bill Lotter has
been doing, trying to add
recurrency to the models.
Trying to have both
feedback connections as well
as recurrent connections
within each layer
to try to get a model that
will be able to perform pattern
completion, and therefore,
use these feedback
signals to allow
us to extrapolate
from previous information
about these objects.
Bill will be here Friday
or Monday, I'm not sure.
So you should talk to him
more about these models.
Essentially, they belong
to the family of HMAX.
They belong to a family
of convolutional networks,
where you have filter
operations, threshold,
and saturation pooling
on normalization.
Jim will say about
this family of models
today in the afternoon.
These are purely
bottom-up models.
And what Bill has been doing
is other than recurrent
and feedback connections,
retraining these models based
on these recurrent and
feedback connections,
and then comparing
their performance
with human psychophysics.
So this is the behavioral
data that I showed you before.
This is the performance
of the feedforward model.
This is the recurrent model
that was able to train.
Another way to try to
get out whether feedback
is relevant for
pattern completion
is to use with backward masking.
Backward masking means
that you present an image,
and immediately
after that image,
within a few milliseconds,
you present noise.
You present a mask.
And people have argued
that masking essentially
interrupts feedback processing.
Essentially, it
allows you to have
a bottom-up flow of
information-- stops feedback.
I don't think this is
quite extremely rigorous.
I think that the story is
probably far more complicated
than that.
But to a first approximation,
you present a picture,
you have a bottom-up
stream, you put a mask,
and you interrupt all the
subsequent feedback processing.
So if you do that at
the behavioral level,
you can show that when stimuli
are masked, particularly
if the interval is very short,
you can significantly impair
pattern completion performance.
So if the mask comes
within 25 milliseconds
of the actual
stimulus performance
in recognizing these
heavily occluded objects
is significantly impaired.
We interpreted this to
indicate that feedback may be
needed for pattern completion.
This is Bill's instantiation
of that recurrent model.
Because he has
recurrency now, he also
has time in this models.
So he can also
present the image,
present the mask to the model,
and compare the performance
of the computational
model as a function
of the occlusion in unmasked
and the masked conditions.
So to summarize this-- and
there's still two or three more
slides that I want to show--
I've given you three
examples of potential ways
in which feedback
signals can be important.
The first one has to do
with the effects of feedback
on surround suppression,
going from V2 to V1.
We think that by doing this
type of experiments combined
with the computational
models to understand what
are the fundamental
computations,
we can begin to elucidate
some of the steps
by which feedback
can exert its role.
We hoped to come up with
the essential alphabet
of computations similar to the
filtering and normalization
operations that are
implemented by feedback.
The second example
was feedback as being
able to have features
that dictate what
we do in visual search
tasks and the last example,
in both our preliminary
work, trying to use feedback,
as well as recurrent connections
to perform pattern completion
and extrapolate from
prior information.
So the last thing I
wanted to do is just
flash a few more
slides about a couple
of things that are happening in
neuroscience and computational
neuroscience that I
think are tremendously
exciting for people.
If I were young again,
these are some of the things
that I would definitely be very,
very excited to follow up on.
So the notion that we'll
be able to go inside brains
and read our biological code,
and eventually write down
computer code, and build
amazing machines is, I think,
very appealing and sexy.
But at the same time,
it's a far cry, right?
We're a long way from being
able to take biological codes
and translate that into
computational codes.
It's really extremely tragic.
So here are three
reasons why I think
there's optimism that this may
not be as crazy as it sounds.
We're beginning to have
tremendous information
about wiring diagrams
at exquisite resolution.
There are a lot of
people who are seriously
thinking about providing
us with maps about which
neuron talks to
which other neuron.
And this was not
present ever before.
So we are now beginning to
have detailed information
that it's much higher resolution
connectivity than ever before.
The second one is the
strength in numbers.
For decades, we've
been recording
the activity of one
neuron at a time,
maybe a few neurons at a time.
Now there are many different
ideas and techniques out there
by which we can
listen to and monitor
the activity of multiple
neurons simultaneously.
And I think this is
going to be game changing
for neurophysiology, but
also for the possibility
of reputational models that
are inspired by biology.
And the third one is a series
of techniques mostly developed
by people like Ed Boyden
and Karl Deisseroth
to do optogenetics, and to
manipulate these circuits
with unprecedented resolution.
So let me expand on
that for one second.
This is the C. elegans.
This is an intramicroscopy
image of how one
can categorize the circuitry.
So it turns out that this
pioneering work of Sydney
Brenner a couple
of decades ago has
led to mapping the connectivity
of each one of the 302 neurons.
How exactly for each neuron,
who it's connected with.
And this is represented
in that rather complex way
in this diagram here.
Well, it turns out
that people are
beginning to do these type
of heroic type of experiments
in cortex.
So we're beginning to
have initial insights
about connectivity
about how neurons
are wired with each other at
this resolution in cortex.
We're nowhere near being able
to have these for humans.
Not even other species,
mice, and so on.
Not even Drosophila yet.
There's a huge amount of
[INAUDIBLE] and interest
in the community of having
a very detailed map.
So the question for you for
the young and next generation,
what are we going to
do with these maps.
If I give you a fantastic
detailed wiring diagram
of a chunk of
cortex, how is that
going to transform our ability
to make inferences, and build
new computational models.
The second one has to
do with our ability
to start the recording
for more and more neurons.
This is that other I didn't
have time to talk about.
This is work also that Hanlin
did with Matias Ison and Itzhak
Fried.
These are recordings of
spikes from human cortex,
again, in patients
that have epilepsy.
I'm just flashing this slide
because I had it handy.
These are 300 neurons.
This is not a simultaneously
recorded population.
These are cases where we can
record from a few neurons
at a time using micro wires now.
This is different from
the type of recording
that I showed you before.
These are actual spikes
that we can record.
And these 380 neurons
is in a different task.
So recording from
these 318 neurons
took us about three
to four years of time.
There are more and
more people that
are using either
two photon imaging
and/or massive multielectrode
arrays that are beginning
to be able to record the
activity of hundreds of neurons
simultaneously.
My good friend and crazy
inventor, Ed Boyden,
believes that we will be able
to recover from 100,000 neurons
simultaneously.
Of course, he is far
more grandiose than I am,
and he can think big
at this kind of scale.
But even to think about the
possibility of recording
from 1,000 or 5,000
neurons simultaneously so
that in a week or
a month, one may
be able to have a
tremendous amount
from a very large population.
This is going to
be transformative.
Three decades ago in the
field of molecular biology,
people would sequence
a single gene,
and they would publish
the entire sequence--
ACCGG-- and so on.
That was the whole paper.
A grad student would
spend five years just
sequencing a single gene.
Now we have the possibility
of downloading genome
by advances in technology.
I suspect that a lot
of our recordings
will become obsolete.
We'll be able to listen to
the activity of thousands
of neurons simultaneously.
And again, it's
for your generation
to think about how
this will transform
our understanding of how quick
we can read biological codes.
In the unlikely event that you
think that that's not enough,
here's one more
thing that I think
is transforming how we can
decipher biological codes.
And that's again, Ed
Boyden using techniques
that are referred to
as optogenetics, where
you can manipulate the activity
of specific types of neurons.
I flashed a lot of
computational models today.
A lot of hypotheses about
what different connections may
be doing.
At some point, we
will be able to test
some of those hypotheses with
unprecedented resolution.
So if somebody wanted to
know what is this neuron V2,
what kind of feedback
its providing,
we may be able to silence
only neurons in V2 that
provide feedback to
V1 in a clean manner
without affecting,
for example, all
of the other feed-forward
processes, and so on.
So the amount of
specificity that
can be derived from these type
of techniques is enormous.
So that's all I wanted to say.
So because we have very high
specificity in our ability
to manipulate
circuits, because we'll
be able to record the activity
of many, many more neurons
simultaneously,
and because we'll
have more and more
detailed diagrams,
I think that the dream of being
able to read out and decode
biological codes, and translate
those into competition codes
is less crazy than it may sound.
We think that in the next
several years and decades,
smart people like you
will be able to make
this tremendous
transformation and discover
specific algorithms
about intelligence
by taking direct
inspiration from biology.
So that's what's
illustrated here.
We'll be happy to
keep on fighting.
Andrei and I will fight.
We will be happy to keep on
fighting about Eva and how
amazing she is and she isn't.
What I try to describe is
that by really understanding
biological codes,
we'll be able to write
amazing computational code.
I put a lot of arrows here.
I'm not claiming QED.
I'm not saying that
we solve the problem.
There's a huge amount of
work that we need in here.